اهلا بكم الى موجز لاهم الانباء حضر
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان في تساليني
منفصلين مع الرئيسين الروسي والاكرانيه من
مخاطر اطاله امد الحرب واكد اردوغان ان
اللقاءات بين مسؤوليه الاستخبارات الروسيه
والامريكيه في تركيا ستلعب دورنا رئيسيا
في منع التصعيد وفي موسكو قال متحدث باسم
الكريم لان الحوار مع الغرب يمكن ان يصبح
عنصر قويا في المفاوضات بين روسيا
واوكرانيا لانك تنفيذ توجيهات الغرب بدقه
تعبيره وقال الرئيس الاوكراني
مع الرئيس التركي سبل التعاون في مجالي
الامن والطاقه
اوكرانيا ستظل ضامنا الاستقرار الغذاء
العالمي
اعلنا المدعي العام السويدي العثور على
اثار مواده متفجره بالقرب من خطي انابيب
نور ستريم واحد واثنين ما يؤكد تعرض
الخطين لعمل تخريبي في سبتمبر الماضي وفق
تعبيره وقال المدعي العام السويدي ان
تحقيقات في مسرح الجريمه في بحر البلطيق
اظهرت اثار متفجرات على العديد من الاجسام
الغريبه التي عثر عليها
قال المتحدث باسم الرئاسه الروسيه
ترحب بالتاكيد السويده فرضيه الهجوم
الارهابيه على خطوط انابيب غاز نور ستريم
واكد ان هذا يؤكد مره اخرى الصدقيه
المعلومات التي تملكها روسيا مشددين على
ضروره تحديد الجهه التي تقف وراء هذا لم
تجاره
نقلت وكاله الانباء الفرنسيه عن زعيم
كوريا الشماليه كيم جونغ اون قوله انه
سيستخدم اسلحه نوويه للرد على التهديدات
الجهه اخرى قالت وكاله رويترز ان مجلس
الامن الدولي سيعقد اجتماعا يوم الاثنين
لبحث الملف الكوري الشمالي ذلك بعد اعلان
كوريا الجنوبيه ان كوريا الشماليه اطلقت
ما يبدو انه صاروخ بالستيون عابر للقارات
وقد عقدت نائبه الرئيس الامريكي اجتماعا
طارئا مع عقدته خمس دول على همشي قمه ابيك
في بانكوك واكدت واشنطن انها تتخذ
الاجراءات الضروريه لضمان امن اليابان
وكوريا الجنوبيه
واجر الجيش الكوري والجنوبي تدريبات على
اطلاق النار ضد اهداف ان تحاكي قاذفه
الصواريخ المحموله لكوريا الشماليه كما
اجرت القوات الامريكيه واليابانيه مناورات
ممثله
عربيات الخارجيه الصينيه عن املها في ان
تسعى الاطراف الى تسويه سياسيه تعالج
مخاوف كل طرف بطريقه متوازنه من خلال
الحوار وقالت الخارجيه الصينيه ان منع
التصعيد في شبه الجزيره الكوريه يصب في
مصلحه الجميع المجتمع الدولي باسره
حكم هذا الموجز شكرا لكم والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]